okay so the topic of this video is the
cellular division process known as
meiosis you know I challenge you to come
back to this animation right here at the
end at the end when you're done and you
think you have a good understanding come
back to this animation here and to try
to talk out the events that are
happening in this animation the
animation is only 15 seconds long or so
but try to talk out what's happening
once you think you have a good
understanding and just see if you can
talk your way through it so let's go
ahead though and get started okay so
let's go ahead and get started first of
all the definition of meiosis meiosis is
the process where the chromosome number
of a cell will be reduced by half the
picture here the picture here I see two
chromosome one is two chromosome eight
two chromosome 12s and two chromosome
18s this is a karyotype of a diploid
cell so cells that undergo meiosis are
going to start diploid so a human cell
that undergoes meiosis
we'll start with 46 chromosomes however
when meiosis is finished read the
definition it's the process where the
chromosome number is reduced by half
watch how the picture changes when
meiosis is finished the cell will end
haploid there's only going to be one
chromosome number one and one chromosome
nine and one chromosome twelve in humans
a cell that undergoes meiosis
we'll start with 46 chromosomes but
we'll end with 23 meiosis makes haploid
cells so meiosis is what makes the
haploid cells called gametes so meiosis
makes haploid egg cells and meiosis
makes haploid sperm cells these again
are called the gametes and when meiosis
is finished the end result will be not
just two cells like mitosis created but
four I already mentioned the cells are
going to be haploid but meiosis is going
to create four cells here we see a
picture of four cells that were created
by the process of meiosis
okay so let's get into the first step of
the cell cycle if you recall interphase
it's not a part of mitosis and
interphase is not a part of meiosis
either but interphase is a part of the
entire life of the cell known as the
cell cycle you know before we get
started I want to put a note in the
upper left hand corner if you look in
this animation there in the cell there
are six strands of DNA in the cell at
the start of this animation three
strands of DNA black three strands of
DNA in red so I want to put that note in
the upper left hand corner just as a
reminder at the beginning of this
animation there were six strands of DNA
in this cell
well let's go through the stages of
interphase now in my previous video I
also explained the steps of interphase
and
it's the same process as my previous
video now I mentioned in the previous
video that interphase is subdivided into
three categories category number or
subcategory number one is called the g1
stage the cell grows and it makes sense
if the cell is about to divide and split
it makes sense that it should grow and
get bigger also mention that additional
organelles are created additional
lysosomes additional vacuoles additional
ribosomes and again it should make sense
if the cell is about to divide and split
it should make sense to make more parts
that way every cell that's created will
have its own supply of parts then
there's the second stage of interphase
called the S stage the S stands for the
word synthesis in the word synthesis
just literally means to make so in the
synthesis stage the S stage the cell is
going to make something and what it's
going to make is the loose stringy
version of DNA called chromatin in my
animation those six pieces of chromatin
are going to be duplicated in the 12 you
know in a human cell humans have 46
pieces of DNA 46 strands of chromatin
that would double and duplicate into 92
but in this animation we're going to
follow a cell that had six strands of
DNA but it just doubled into 12
then there is what's called the g2 stage
it's the second growth stage and the
cell will grow again get larger after
all it's about the split and divide so
the interphase stage that we described
in the previous video is really the same
as in this video well now let's go ahead
and jump into meiosis here we go
okay so let's actually get into meiosis
now the first stage of meiosis is called
prophase number one there eventually
will be a prophase number two but let's
not get too far ahead of ourselves
prophase number one first of all in the
animation the chromosomes are going to
form the loose linear versions of DNA
called chromatin are going to wind up
and condense into these X shaped
chromosomes I'll explain in a few
moments why I labeled some chromosomes I
know Mom number one and dad number one
and mom number two and dad number two
I'll explain while I did that in a few
minutes another thing that happens in
prophase number one is the nucleus is
going to dissolve so these two things
that I just mentioned the chromosomes
forming in the nucleus dissolving this
happened in prophase of mitosis as well
so prophase of mitosis and prophase
number one of meiosis are shaping up to
be pretty similar so far however a
couple of important events also occur in
prophase number one of meiosis let's
talk about those now so the two events
that take place during prophase number
one of meiosis that are unique to
meiosis is the event called synapses
which is the pairing of homologous
chromosomes and this is why I labeled
the chromosomes from mom or from dad
what's going to happen is dad's
chromosome number one will pair with
mom's chromosome number one the two
chromosome number ones will pair up side
by side the two chromosome twos will
pair up side by side the two chromosome
threes will pair up side by side in this
animation here I made all of dad
chromosomes chromosomes that you
inherited from your father I made them
all red and I made all the chromosomes
you inherited from your mother black
so in the animation you saw synapses
occur and now what we have are these
groupings of two chromosomes these are
called tetrads these grouping groupings
of chromosomes are called tetrads and
the reason for the the name tetrad if
you know the prefix tetra tetra is a
prefix that means four well if you
recall that one chromosome is made from
two chromatids therefore these two
chromosomes of a tetrad are actually
four chromatids and that's why they get
the name of a tetrad and so this happens
during prophase number one and this
event is called synapses well there has
to be a reason for this to happen let's
see what that is once the two chromatid
once the two chromosomes have paired up
next to each other once the chromosome
number three that you inherited from dad
pairs up with the chromosome three you
inherited from mom an event called
crossing over occurs and I think I can
visually show crossing over better than
I can explain it so let's go ahead and
let me show you what I mean by crossing
over let's zoom on into this tetrad that
I have highlighted here and here we have
again in red the chromosome number one
that you inherited from your father and
in black the chromosome number one you
inherited from your mother the
definition of crossing over is simply
the exchange of genes watch what happens
during the process called crossing over
chunks of chromosomes will break off and
reconnect so a chunk of dads red
chromosome broke away and reconnected to
moms a chunk of the black chromosome
that you inherited from your mother
broke off and connected to the
chromosome you inherited from your
father
well let's zoom back out and take a look
at the entire cell so now that we've
zoomed back out you can see the tetrad
on the left has experienced crossing
over but the two other tetrads have not
so there you just saw crossing over
occur and here it is again so now that
crossing over occurs in each of the
Tetra
that's what this does I can't stress
this enough the importance of crossing
over is it creates genetic diversity
eventually meiosis is going to create
sperm cells and egg cells and because of
crossing over each of them is
genetically unique at the end they're
all going to all the cells that are made
by meiosis are going to be different
genetically different and you'll see
that as we continue on so as we move on
into metaphase number one of meiosis the
homologous chromosomes again the tetrads
are going to align along the cell's
equator you recall the spindle fibers
will grow from centrioles attach
themselves to the centromere and pull
the chromosomes to the middle or the
equator of the cell okay as we move on
into anaphase number one the chromosomes
are still in the middle of the cell that
happened during metaphase number one but
in anaphase number one the tetrads are
going to be separated now I've got three
tetrads in this animation I have
attached right on top a tetrad in the
middle attachment on the bottom so in a
moment in my animation remember that a
tetrad is made from two homologous
chromosomes they're going to be pulled
to opposite ends of the cell so the tet
right on top in a moment the hamada one
homologous chromosome will be pulled to
the left by spindle fibers one
homologous chromosome will be pulled to
the right by spindle fibers the tet
right in the middle one homologous
chromosome of the tet right in the
middle we pulled to the left one
homologous chromosome of the tet red in
the middle we pulled to the right and
finally at the bottom the bottom tetrad
spindle fibers are going to pull one
homologous chromosome to the left one
homologous chromosome to the right here
we see in the animation the tetrads are
being separated so in anaphase number
one the Tet Reds are separated and that
leaves one homologous chromosome at each
end of the cell so if we look at
telophase number one of meiosis
well cytokinesis is going to divide and
split the cell and there you can see
cytokinesis dividing and splitting the
cytoplasm we now have the formation of
two cells here
sometimes the nucleus will regrow
sometimes it doesn't in this animation
I'm going to have the nucleus regrow
around the chromosomes that you see in
those two cells and each cell is going
to contain the one of the homologous
chromosomes but note that the full in
the chromosomes are still full and
intact
they haven't been ripped apart yet in
the chromatids that will happen just not
yet
and so in humans if these two cells were
humans there would be a cell on the left
with 23 full of chromosomes and a cell
on the right with 23 full chromosomes
but this isn't the end this is only the
end of meiosis number one now we go into
meiosis number two and meiosis number
two begins with prophase number two by
the way that's a Roman Roman numeral two
that is not prophase eleven its prophase
number two Roman numerals and so
prophase number two and metaphase 2 and
anaphase 2 and telophase 2 they pretty
much follow the same steps as mitosis so
the nucleus is going to dissolve the
spindle fibers are going to form there
you see the nucleus dissolving one thing
I want to point out is that notice how
we went from telophase number one in the
prophase number two there was no second
interphase and that's really important
if you think of the point of meiosis the
point of meiosis is to reduce the amount
of DNA by half so that's why there is no
second interphase if there was a second
interphase there would be a second S
stage and what happens during the S
stage during the S stage the cell makes
more DNA well the purpose of meiosis is
to get rid of and lose half of the DNA
not to make more so that's why there's
no second interphase and so as the cells
move on through metaphase number two of
meiosis number two the remaining
chromosomes are going to line at the
cell's equator and in the animation
there you
see the x-shaped chromosomes are aligned
at the equator of the cell and I'm
hoping you can predict what's going to
happen to those chromosomes during
anaphase number two so now as we look at
anaphase number two the chroma the
chromosomes are going to be ripped apart
one chromatid is pulled to the top of
the cell where the other chromatid is
pulled to the bottom of the cell
remember that one chromosome is made
from what are called sister chromatids
and so that's what happens during
anaphase number two is the sister
chromatids are pulled to opposite ends
of the cell and as move on into
telophase number two cytokinesis is
going to divide those two cells there
you can see dividing into four cells the
nucleus is going to reform on those four
new cells there you see the round
nucleus has reformed one thing I want to
mention is that the chromatids are going
to uncoil into their loose linear
version of DNA called chromatin so in my
animation the chromatids are uncoiling
into chromatin and the end result are
four genetically unique haploid cells
first of all the note in the upper
left-hand corner is still there we
started with six strands of DNA at the
start but now look at the cell at the
top left it only has three strands the
cell on the top right only has three
strands of DNA the cell at the bottom
left has three strands of DNA the cell
at the bottom right has three strands of
DNA we started with the cell that had
six pieces of DNA and we reduced the
number in half to three that's what
meiosis does not only does meiosis make
haploid cells but look at the color of
the three pieces of chromatin each cell
contains a little unique mixture of
separate DNA because of that event
called crossing over that happened way
back in prophase number one each for
each of those four cells has a different
combination of red and black
DNA that's because again of crossing
over so before we wrap up this video I
want to mention some of the little
differences that occur when meiosis is
finished in men versus women males
versus females spermatogenesis is are
kinda there's kind of the events that
take place when meiosis is finished in
males it's kind of how the final touches
of a sperm cell are made before the
cells are technically able to be used to
fertilize an egg so spermatogenesis is a
production of sperm cells in the picture
we have a diploid cell by the name of of
spermatogonium
in this process takes place in male
testes so in male testes males have
millions and millions of these diploid
cells called spermatogonia they're
diploid they have 46 chromosomes but
these four madigan IAM are going to
undergo meiosis
so after meiosis number one that one
spermatogonium will go through meiosis
number one to make two cells and then
those two cells will go through meiosis
number two all those notes that we just
talked about to make four cells now
these four cells aren't quite sperm
cells yet but spermatogenesis does again
is make final changes to the sperm cells
you know males we release a different
set of hormones than females and so the
hormones that males release by our
endocrine system helps to shape and
change these four cells through the
process called spermatogenesis
eventually the sperm cells will grow
tails or flagella they'll take on a
tube-like shape like a torpedo shape so
they hit are more hydrodynamic in order
to to swim in their journey through the
female reproductive system and now again
the pictures just for me being silly
please don't think that sperm cells have
and I have eyes and a smiley face but
you get the idea I hope is that four
cells created by meiosis they have to
undergo through through spermatogenesis
before they are our mature sperm cells
able to fertilize an egg
and so this process again makes four
haploid sperm cells at a time one
diploid spermatogonia will divide into
four mature sperm cells now for women
the process is a little different and I
believe it's pronounced lua genesis
first of all who in genesis is defined
as the production of the egg cell or the
ovum ovum is just the science word for
an egg cell this takes place in woman's
ovaries women have thousands of cells
called blue sites and new site from the
picture you can see is the diploid cell
whose sites go through meiosis meiosis
number one that you sight will divide
into two cells but notice how the cell
on the left is different than the cell
on the right just in terms of size
that's because during meiosis number one
when that site goes through meiosis
number one the cytoplasm is not
distributed evenly the sow on the Left
received the bulk of the cytoplasm the
bulk of the organelles the cell on the
right I don't want to say it's empty and
Hollow but it's not going to be a
functional cell those two cells the big
cell the small cell let's look at the
two let's look at the small cell on the
right first the small cell on the right
will go through meiosis number two to
make two more cells now the big cell on
the left will also go through meiosis
number two to make two more cells so
here as we said in the notes meiosis
makes four cells and there you see four
cells but you can see that during
meiosis number two that big cell didn't
divide evenly again this the bigger
green cell on the left has the bulk of
the cytoplasm the bulk of the organelles
the other little cell I don't get I
don't want to say it's hollow and empty
but it will become a non-functional cell
we call these three non-functional cells
by the way polar bodies now that one
large cell on the left it's not an egg
cell yet it will go through the process
called good Genesis and eventually take
on the form of a finalized egg cell
women released different sex hormones
than men the hormones released by males
allows for mana Genesis to occur the
hormone is released by women in their
endocrine system allows an egg cell or
an ovum to be produced through this
final process called booyah Genesis
those three other polar bodies as my
notes say those three other polar bodies
simply dissolve and the one mature ovum
can then begin the journey of the of the
menstrual cycle and so the the reason
for this picture right here is just a
nice little compare and contrast if you
want to pause the video I'm not going to
say much about this but if you want to
pause the video you can see a nice
compare and contrast mitosis on the Left
versus meiosis on the right and for
those you who are in my biology class
again you feel free to pause the video
again and try to answer these questions
here if you're in my biology class pause
the video in and put your answers on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
meet you before school one day or after
school one day and just go over your
answers with you and see how you did so
pause the video and good luck